practiquemos gráficas de relaciones
proporcionales aquí dice la gráfica
siguiente muestra la relación
proporcional entre la distancia que
recorre un tren y la cantidad de tiempo
que le toma recorrer la entonces viendo
esta gráfica aquí tenemos que la
distancia que el tren recorre está
representada por el eje vertical y
medida en kilómetros ahora en el eje
horizontal tenemos el el tiempo que
tarda el tren en recorrer cierta
distancia el tiempo está medido en horas
y a simple vista podemos ver que esta es
una relación proporcional como lo
sabemos bueno pues el punto 00 está en
la gráfica es decir la gráfica pasa por
el origen en tiempo cero vemos que el
tren ha recorrido cero distancia y
también podemos ver que es una línea la
gráfica representa una relación lineal y
si tienes una relación lineal que pasa
por el origen entonces tienes una
relación proporcional ahora también por
ejemplo puedes verlo observando algunos
puntos por ejemplo el punto
aquí en el punto a podemos podemos ver
que cuando nuestro tiempo es de 4 horas
la distancia recorrida por el tren es de
500 km la distancia recorrida es de 500
kilómetros y veamos por ejemplo en este
punto de aquí en el punto 2,250 vemos
que cuando nuestro tiempo es de 2 horas
la distancia recorrida es de 250
kilómetros
ahora nota que la razón entre entre
estas variables en cualquiera de estos
puntos se mantiene es decir 500 dividido
entre 4 de 125 y 250 dividido entre 2 es
también 125 o si lo prefieres hacer al
revés de tiempo a distancia vemos que
estamos multiplicando por 125 al 4 lo
estamos multiplicando por 125 y al 2 lo
estamos multiplicando por 125 de hecho
podríamos decir lo siguiente podríamos
decir que la distancia entre el tiempo
es igual a 125
es decir nuestra constante de
proporcionalidad
será 125 o si quieres incluir las
unidades como la distancia está en
kilómetros y el tiempo en horas
esto sería 125 kilómetros por horas y
esta será la razón a la cual avanza el
tren entonces la velocidad a la que
avanza el tren es de 125 kilómetros por
hora esta es nuestra constante de
proporcionalidad y bueno en fin ya ha
dicho esto lo que vamos a hacer es
responder a las preguntas que tenemos
aquí abajo dice cuáles proposiciones
sobre la gráfica son verdaderas elige
todas las opciones correctas la
coordenada vertical del punto a
representa la distancia total que
recorre el tren en 500 minutos
veamos dice la coordenada vertical
entonces el punto a tiene coordenada
tiene coordenada 4,500 ahora la
coordenada vertical nos indica cuánto
avanza el tren en ciertas horas es decir
la distancia que recorre en ciertas
horas
entonces se refiere a la segunda
coordenada esta coordenada nos indica la
distancia que hemos recorrido en cuatro
horas así que el eje horizontal nos dice
el tiempo y el eje vertical nos dice la
distancia que recorre el tren la
coordenada vertical del punto ba
representa la distancia total que
recorre el tren en cuatro horas no en
quinientos minutos como dice aquí así
que esta opción no es la correcta esta
opción no es correcta ahora la segunda
opción que nos dice dice el tren recorre
375 kilómetros en tres horas veamos si
esto es correcto a simple vista vemos
que en tres horas parece que el
recorrido del tren ha sido de alrededor
375 kilómetros como vemos aquí pero
para que quede más claro hagamos los
cálculos entonces vamos a dividir 375
kilómetros entre tres horas aquí es
igual esto 375 entre 3 es igual a 125
entonces tenemos 125 kilómetros por hora
que es igual a nuestra constante de
proporcionalidad son iguales entonces es
cierto que en tres horas el tren recorre
375 kilómetros si nos dijeran que el
tren recorre por ejemplo 376 kilómetros
en tres horas
eso sería falso pues no cumpliría con la
constante de proporcionalidad ya que esa
cantidad al dividirla entre tres no es
igual a 125 kilómetros por hora así que
esta opción es correcta y ninguna de las
anteriores no eso no es correcto bueno
hagamos otro ejemplo en este ejemplo
dice la gráfica siguiente muestra el
tiempo necesario para instalar cercado
de diferente longitud
te vemos que tenemos una relación
proporcional porque es una línea que
pasa por el origen entonces qué dicen
las preguntas aquí dice cuáles
proposiciones sobre la gráfica son
verdaderas elige todas las opciones
correctas
la primera opción dice el punto 2,30
muestra que el costo es de 30 pesos por
2 metros de cercado no porque observa
que la coordenada x nos indica el tiempo
es decir el eje horizontal nos indica el
tiempo y la coordenada jr nos dice la
cantidad de cercado que se instaló los
metros de cercado instalados así que el
punto 2,30 nos dice o nos muestra que
toma dos horas instalar 30 metros de
cerca de dos horas en instalar 30 metros
de cercado y no que el costo es de 30
pesos por 2 metros de cercado como lo
dice la primera opción de hecho si
fueran 30 pesos los que se cobran por 2
metros sería una gran oferta así que
bueno esta no es la opción esto no
ahora la segunda opción nos dice que el
punto 460 muestra que toma cuatro horas
instalar 60 metros de cercado sí porque
observa aquí está el punto 460 y la
coordenada x que en este caso es 4 nos
muestra el tiempo que se tarda en
instalar los metros de cercado la
coordenada ye que en este caso es 60 es
la cantidad de metros que se instalaron
entonces 460 nos dice que en 4 horas se
instalaron 60 metros de cercado eso es
correcto en 4 horas recuerda que el eje
horizontal mide el tiempo en cuatro
horas vemos que se instalaron 60 metros
de cercado entonces bueno la segunda
opción es correcta y la tercera ninguna
de las anteriores bueno esa no es una
opción correcta hagamos otro ejercicio
aquí dice un automóvil viaja por una
carretera a la rapidez constante que se
muestra en la gráfica encuentra la
rapidez del auto aquí tenemos esta
gráfica en el eje horizontal vemos que
el tiempo está medido en horas
el eje vertical tenemos la distancia a
la cual es el automóvil
medido en kilómetros también vemos que
es una relación proporcional porque la
razón que existe entre la distancia y el
tiempo es constante y vemos también que
es una línea que pasa por el origen
entonces bueno es una relación
proporcional y para que quede más claro
hagamos lo siguiente voy a dibujar una
tabla
y en esta tabla vamos a tener una
columna que represente al eje horizontal
entonces en esa columna voy a poner
horas y en la otra columna kilómetros
entonces por ejemplo en una hora vemos
que el automóvil viajo 80 kilómetros por
hora lo cual tiene sentido porque
observa que si yo divido 80 kilómetros
pongo 80 kilómetros entre una hora
80 km / una hora esto es igual a 80
kilómetros por hora esto es igual a 80
kilómetros por hora y está 80 kilómetros
por hora esta sería nuestra constante de
proporcionalidad ahora por ejemplo en
dos horas vemos que el automóvil viajo
160 kilómetros y 160 entre 2 eso es
igual a 80
ahora en tres horas vemos que el
automóvil viajo 240 kilómetros 240 entre
eso también es igual a 80 esto nos dice
esto lo que nos dice es lo siguiente
dice que los kilómetros
entre las horas kilómetros entre horas
esto siempre será igual a 80 pues es
nuestra constante de proporcionalidad o
bien también podríamos decir que los
kilómetros que la automóvil avanza es
siempre igual a 80 por las horas que
viaja entonces la rapidez del auto es de
80 kilómetros por hora